. Okay. So the timing of our vacation ended
up being perfect because we had this really
funny voice,
well a couple of weeks ago where someone a
sort of sang to me in the voicemail and I
said, let's uh, anybody who's got some music
production skills, turn this into like an
EDM remix or do a dubstep remix or a parody
or whatever and they just poured in during
the vacation. And I'm going to play some of
them for you today. So this, I think a lot
of people are going to like this. I know some
people get mad when not everything is about
politics, but um, there's a lot of different
things that we talk about on the show. So
I hope you'll enjoy this. Let's start with
some of these are so good. Let me just remind
you, this is the voicemail that came in a
couple of weeks ago. That is the source audio
for much of what we're about to hear today.
Take a listen.
So David Pakman show, it's my favorite show.
You do more good that you know the Jaybird
pack marriage.
Oh, [inaudible]
exactly. So I asked, you know, do something
in the EDM style, do some kind of Dubstep
remix, use your creativity they've poured
in. Okay. I've already had to narrow them
down because there were just so many. This
is a sampling. I do think that there are actually
some contenders here for becoming our actual
new intro theme song for the podcast, radio
show and television show. So I'm gonna name
these by number. I apologize in advance if
yours didn't make it. It's not that I didn't
like it, it's that I had to do some sampling,
some sub selection, because otherwise this
would take all day. Um, if you want to vote
on, which should be the new theme song, I'm
going to tell you the number. So I'll say
this is number one. This is number two. There's
only one way to vote. And that's by email
using the contact form on our website.
It's just, it's too hard to comb through youtube
comments and Twitter mentions and stuff like
that. So go to David pakman.com click on contact.
Say I'm voting for number one, number two,
number three, whatever. You can even just
do it in the subject line and then you can,
you know, I guess you probably have to fill
in the body to send the message, but you don't
have to say much other than theme song. I'm
voting number one, two, three, four, whatever.
Uh, you can also say, by the way, keep the
current theme song if you prefer that we don't
have to change it, but there's some really
good stuff here. So the first submission that
I will play is from Art Flores. Take a listen
to this one.
[inaudible]
sort of Downtempo
okay,
you're welcome.
Okay.
Do you want it anyway?
Okay,
so I think you get the idea. That's number
one. Okay. Number one from Art Flores. This
is option number two from psycho Nordea. I
hope I'm, I'm pronouncing that correctly.
Take a listen.
[inaudible]
Very Darren
[inaudible].
All right, so that's number two. Option two
from psycho Nadia. Here is number three. This
is from Andrew worst. Okay. Very different.
Take a listen.
[inaudible]
a big lead up on this one.
So Jay fitting pack Paquin show my favorite
show. You do more going down, you'll go the
gay man pass [inaudible]
819-ONE-NINE-2192 David p. I like that. Nine
two one nine two one nine voicemail them.
[inaudible] know.
Okay, so that's number three from Andrew worst.
All right. This next one is number four, extremely
high production value. Okay. This one is from,
I dunno if it's pronounced three lawn and
the chosen masters or maybe it's just alon
with a three. I hope I'm pronouncing it correctly.
This has number of parts. This, this is a,
a of a extremely cinematic in nature. Take
a listen to this.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] I don't remember [inaudible] there's
even more to it.
Oh. [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah.
Okay. I think you get the idea. That is really
something else. So that's number four from
three lawn or Ilan and the chosen masters.
Okay. Number five. The only name I have for
this one is, sorry for bad English. That I
don't know if that's a a handle or what. Let's
take a listen. This is number five now.
[inaudible]
when you go to my favorite, you know, [inaudible]
my favorite. You know you do work on their,
you know, when you [inaudible] [inaudible].
Okay.
Again, that was number five from, sorry for
bad English. And then lastly, this is number
six from Rob Bennett. Okay, so one through
six. This is number six.
Fifth tackle video.
[inaudible] 15 1515 [inaudible]
it's my favorite show. Give you more [inaudible].
Yeah,
I think sounding a little bit out of sync
in that one, but I still like it and it has
some great stuff. So one through six. All
right. Get in touch via email from the website.
David pakman.com contact us. Tell me one through
six or keep the current theme song. If you
don't know that we have a theme song because
you just watch clips on Youtube or whatever
and you don't realize that the podcast, radio
and TV show have an intro theme song, then
I don't know what you should do. Maybe don't
email me. No, I mean, I guess just tell me
which one of these you like and if you don't
think any of them are suitable, then let me
know enough. None of them are suitable but
awesome, awesome stuff. Those are just six
of what must have been like 20 or so and appreciate
everybody who send them in. I sent them in,
even if it didn't make the final six. Look
forward to hearing from people. I guess we'll
give it like a week and maybe early next week
I'll announce the results of the vote by mail.